hey kids listen to me right now what
you're gonna learn in flipping
right now is gonna be foundational skill
sets that you'll be able to use in
perpetuity and while everybody's judging
you
from your mom to your grandma to your
neighbor you're learning actual skills
of survival in actual life so tell them
to go [ __ ] themselves when they're mad
that you got a d
in science [ __ ] you misgusting but you
flipped 84 pairs
for 400 bucks in profit see how small i
said it's not about how much
it's the skill set that you're gaining
[Applause]
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
take care of yourself stay well bro nice
meeting you guys
with two or three you have to go
[Music]
just did a show on complex about
sneakers that was nice
that's my outro d i'm in operations mode
i got a [ __ ] company around here
are you 26 years old
26. are you 26 years old
because if you are i just want to remind
you that i worked the cash register
in a liquor store in new jersey at your
age
be patient
[Music]
hot tip if you're meeting me for the
first time and you work for me
blueberries is always a good strategy
yeah because when gary vaynerchuk throws
a party
vaynersports and and 137 do not get as
much
benefit as we want because everyone's
like you going to the garyvee party
tonight
people don't even know who gary
vaynerchuk is that's how crazy braiding
works
they're like they're like hey i'm like
hey i'm like i'm gary vaynerchuk like
cool
and then like somebody's like gary vee
but you're gary vee like you're looking
at me i'm a human you know what i look
like
and because i said vaynerchuk you're
still confused that's branding
of course and she took some different
turns so she didn't do
the study abroad thing and you know in
fact
that's when we went
a little more family-oriented yeah you
know looking forward to coming back home
not looking for an apartment outside
yeah i get it
i lived at home the first year i think
yeah first nine months yeah so
i i want to live with my parents now
that's what i said i was like
i'm not leaving i'm with you i'm all
about that the biggest advantage of the
kitchen and cooking why am i leaving i
live in this shitty apartment i was like
i'm gonna stay here take advantage of it
and they're [ __ ] thrilled to have you
yeah yeah absolutely
it's awesome for me
um i have um
so these are um toilet deodorizing
tablets love
if you're familiar with like the sprays
yeah this is an elite that's
yeah basically for you and team gary
kitty
there we go beautiful come here
thank you such a pleasure so if we can
yes
um so i've only seen like 200 episodes
that was in the podcast
you mentioned in askgaryvee299
uh you're with bill you mm-hmm
you talked about taking 49 of companies
and running them through
have you been doing investing like you
made a lot of money yep
that's not as fun as it sounds right
it's not i hate it i'm kind of over it
completely almost
i get i want to do some sort of like
incubator i don't want to invest anymore
i want to find kids that and you and old
people like i don't give a [ __ ]
people that have like a three to seven
million dollar business and i want them
to give me 49
of it and then i want to like just plug
it in and make it to
a hundred yeah i think i can do that
consistently could i interest you in
doing that
so i mean the answer is your timing is
incredible because we're further along
in that
internally you send me an email that
says that the guy just stopped by with
like all in the title
in that 49 percent in the body you need
to give me context
a little bit like okay where's miss sad
okay top line
like just give me some context okay to
decide if we should get into a meeting
okay fair enough fair enough pleasure
awesome thank you
soon this is going to throw a lot of
people off yeah i'm pumped to send my
kids to college
yeah i just don't think it's required i
need to watch them and reverse engineer
them
with my advice and let them do their
thing that's that's where i'm at
that's the framework we're in a shifting
mindset on that now
i think parents i think parents who have
little kids right now are not going to
be
as pushy about going to college because
they're also going to understand the
financial equation
if you're a parent and you have a little
kid right now and you recognize you've
got 15 years about digging yourself out
of student debt you're not about to
couldn't agree more
couldn't agree more couldn't couldn't
agree more
wait let's talk about pantsing who in
this room by show of hands knows what
pantsing is
i mean who doesn't well saddam was in
turkey so
so for anybody at home that doesn't how
old are you
i love that no he does which is why i
asked him is i'm pumped that pantsing
continues
because in this environment i'm not like
there were girls
in my high school that got pantsed in
the middle of the hallway yeah like on
some really politically incorrect [ __ ]
well i can't do that let me just set the
stage as the old dog in the room
when i was in high school the only thing
guys could wear were boxers
like hardcore boxers like no other
underwear was acceptable
not tidy whities not like whatever
whatever boxer briefs thank you
only thing acceptable was baggy boxers
the amount of
my friends thank god this never happened
to me
the amount of my friends that got
pantsed in the hallway
yeah and both shorts and boxers went
because of the nature like i feel like
modern day pantsing because briefs and
like other things
was everybody who got pants
got naked not
you see their underwear naked some real
[ __ ] jesse janae is one of my favorite
entrepreneurs that i've ever met
everybody thank you so much for scanning
the bottle uh
i'm gary vaynerchuk one of the
co-founders of empathy wines
[Music]
hello hello everyone i am well
how are you here how's it going so far
well there's a lot of stuff uh okay
great i'd love to go around
introduce yourself uh where you're from
and what you do
and then we'll go back around and do q a
and um i would make that very selfish
um because that's you know you get
you've consumed pretty
plenty of macro free advice me but i'd
love to make sure i
deliver on what your singular question
is here so let's go
yeah we were and i started my company in
a conference room of another company
like we were like people like kind of
continue to forget that
when you you started from ground zero
you're like 30 friends
or no respect we were we were small
for a long time because the first two
years i was pretty passive i mean i
think when i took over
two and a half years in i think we were
less than 30.
that's awesome yeah we like we got crazy
when i started running it full time
i just love hiring people that's not a
joke
so good um yeah so if you can think back
then yeah give me i mean couple core
things disproportionate over
communication with every single person
that's in it
excellent like the game-changing reason
why vaynermedia is still foundationally
strong
is how close i was to the first hundred
employees it still permeates
it'll rear its head later of like old
vayner new like there's many things that
will come from it later
but it is the num honestly it's raising
a child
over love the [ __ ] out of your kid in
the first four years
and see ridiculous dividends later like
you know
later you can worry about entitlement
but at four they can't be entitled just
love the [ __ ] out of them
later you can like not let them win are
you
you're the guy you you have to build a
real relationship with all of them
thanks for the post you post yesterday
it's very sweet uh
you have to build a real relationship
and and you have to manage all of them
differently you have to manage them
based on them
not based on you at 12 and 20
like you're gonna have that awesome
culture like you know people gonna stay
later you're close as [ __ ]
cut out the cancer quick okay if you by
accident
[ __ ] up and hired somebody you gotta
get you know give her
or him real rap the only time i'm pretty
radical candor is
when they're a singular cancer in a
small group
where i'm like hey like nobody likes you
well i'm the best employee i'm like cool
i'm still gonna fire you
that the best employee isn't the one who
makes the most money or the client likes
the best
it's the holistic best and all 11 people
in this office don't love the way you're
rolling
so that's important early cancer is
important because it keeps like positive
vibes
it's a very nurturi i think i think the
first four years of company
are disproportionately nurturing
tyler yeah biggest misconception of
what's going on here
in life nope in our world hey reid okay
ah that we're focused by our lack of
focus
or our chaos that's exactly right that's
exactly right
creates a misconception around a lack of
focus and strategic chaos
i love it how's it going austin how are
we doing tyler
that's awesome
about to do the show
yes sir thank you brother real pleasure
how are you
good and this is a good time for me to
give you these guys this i'll give you
oh
i got you guys my grip yes
we are yeah it was super quick here's my
opening here's my thing thank you my big
thing is
i hope you guys flip it yeah that would
not hurt my
as a matter of fact because i grew up on
baseball cards flipping at the us one
flea market
which we just referenced this is my core
of my interest and so for me i don't
want to be a hypocrite i lived my life
going and buying shaq figures at the
dollar store and flipping them at
baseball card shows
so even if my friends if they flip it
that like makes me weirdly happy because
that's what they decided
thank you bro thank you very much uh
so yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't have any
feelings towards that
when i give i give without expectation
so if i'm giving you a pair of sneakers
i'm giving it early because you're my
friends and i want you to have it
and if you decide the right move for you
is to flip it then that makes me happy
i'm being dead serious about that
how are you you're looking you're in the
calendar now this is by like
this is get ready people's
complete misunderstanding of how busy i
actually am
you